ultimately chain mails yeah kind of
breath every time I move but this is
gorgeous thank you they do so much
thanks it was a fight
I'm Atelier Versace wow that you done
good besides you're doing good what's
the biggest secret you got going on with
your dress with my dress probably about
seven different layers of corsets
probably used to the corsets huh oh yes
I am
breathing is like so iterated so no need
I'm like looking behind me being laid
did you just get your foot in my back to
my place
when you get a scrape for getting the
ferns and you just immediately like
looking through it and find out what's
happening now yes I'm like the biggest
fan of the show it's ridiculous I have
to read everything and obsessively and
as soon as they come in sometimes you
tell people in the room they're like why
did you tell us that now we're
heartbroken
so I would just stop telling people I
get eaten by a dragon that's what
happens hey my drag doesn't not a
spoiler that is a joke I'm lying